[Música]
hola bienvenidos a áfrica 7 días este es
un magazine 100 dedicado al continente
africano mi nombre es andrés meza muñoz
y estos son nuestros titulares etiopía
oficializó la puesta en marcha de su
controvertida mega presa en el nilo para
la producción eléctrica el proyecto
representa la mayor instalación
hidroeléctrica de áfrica y ha sido el
origen de una disputa diplomática entre
el gobierno etíope egipto y sudán
a pesar de la distancia geográfica la
guerra en ucrania también podría afectar
a áfrica especialmente en el suministro
de alimentos al continente analizamos
las posibles consecuencias y los lazos
de los países africanos con las partes
en guerra
el tour de ciclismo de ruanda terminó el
domingo en la capital kigali en este
país el 80% del equipo nacional de
ciclismo es compuesto por antiguos
visita existas tendremos un reportaje de
nuestra corresponsal en ruanda
[Música]
empezamos en etiopía que después de más
de una década de obras puso en marcha la
llamada gran presa del renacimiento en
el nilo azul para la producción de
electricidad el primer ministro etíope a
bit ahmet definió el inicio de la
producción de la gran presa como el
nacimiento de una nueva era se trata de
un proyecto multimillonario que está en
disputa con sudán y egipto dos países
que también dependen del nilo para sus
recursos hídricos el cairo había
afirmado durante la época colonial un
tratado que le garantizaba un derecho de
veto sobre construcciones en el río sin
embargo a etiopía no formaba parte de
este acuerdo y nunca se consideró
obligada por él en 2010 un nuevo tratado
firmado por los países de la cuenca del
nilo eliminó el veto egipcio y autorizó
los proyectos de empresas
hidroeléctricas
porque esta corte de cinta el primer
ministro etíope aviv med inauguró por
todo lo alto la puesta en marcha de la
producción de electricidad de la presa
del renacimiento se necesitaron 10 años
de trabajo para construir la estructura
hidráulica la mayor jamás construida en
áfrica con 145 metros de altura y 1.8
kilómetros de longitud ya está en
funcionamiento el principal motivo
fueron las dificultades de financiación
los etíopes han tenido que rebuscar en
sus bolsillos para financiar la
infraestructura cuyo coste se estima en
4 mil 200 millones de dólares aunque es
un orgullo nacional para etiopía la
presa ha sido motivo de disputa con
egipto y sudán desde que se puso en
marcha el proyecto en 2011 esto se debe
a que obtiene sus recursos del nilo azul
el principal afluente del nilo del que
ambos países dependen agua como puedes
ver el agua generará energía mientras
fluya como fluía previamente a escaso
daño egipto eso a diferencia de los
rumores que dicen que el pueblo y el
gobierno etíopes están regresando el
agua para matar de hambre
y el cairo que anunció en enero que
había caído por debajo del umbral de
pobreza de agua se niega a permitir que
etiopía llene la presa con demasiada
rapidez y amenaza regularmente con una
intervención militar el verano pasado la
onu recomendó que continuaran las
conversaciones diplomáticas entre los
tres países pero esto no impidió que te
opi a lanzar a la segunda fase del
relleno en julio había of met que
promete vender la energía producida a
precios de coste a sus vecinos afirma
que la presa beneficiará al desarrollo
económico de toda la región
la mayoría de los países de áfrica se
han mantenido en silencio ante la
ofensiva rusa a ucrania a excepción de
ghana kenia y gabón que condenaron la
escalada de conflicto y también de
sudáfrica que pidió una mediación para
detener la guerra y es que el continente
mantiene lazos importantes con las
partes en guerra así nos lo explica
david soler periodista y codirector de
áfrica mundi punto es si es para que
áfrica tiene relaciones con rusia desde
la época de la unión sindical sobre todo
con la geografía el comunismo se
expandió en muchos movimientos de
liberación es socialmente al sur del
continente pero termino en algunos en
áfrica occidental y ahora mismo la
relación que tiene con ahora rusia es
más de venta de temas de seguridad por
ejemplo el grupo ruso waldner está cada
vez más presente en el continente y el
ruso es el principal exportador de
además al continente africano con un 30
por ciento de todas las que llegan al
continente por parte de ucrania las
relaciones no son tan estrechas sí que
es verdad que allí hay ahora mismo
muchos estudiantes tanto marroquíes
nigerianos
egipcios y la meses en total son 1 de
cada 5 estudiantes extranjeros en
ucrania es africano y por lo tanto es la
relación más actual pero de todos modos
a ucrania no hay relaciones históricas
tan tan hechas sin que se le dé más como
un socio dentro del marco europeo
lo que podría ser las relaciones con la
unión europea
sabéis soler también nos mencionó cómo
podría afectar esta guerra a áfrica
bueno esta guerra es importante para
áfrica en varios motivos principalmente
porque un crónicos ya exportan más del
30 por ciento del trigo mundial
principalmente para hacer un egipto
recibe el 75 por ciento de su trigo de
rusia entonces el precio de los
alimentos puede subir muchos relacionan
regiones como por ejemplo una barra de
pan y eso puede llevar a muchas
protestas recordemos que en sudán por
ejemplo el exdictador algo así fue
al final echarlo del gobierno por los
protestantes por unas protestas que
empezaron por el crecimiento de los
precios del pan
otro factor donde puede
aceptar la guerra de ucrania a áfrica es
principalmente en la energía si rusia
corta con la unión europea muchos de sus
suministros de gas y petróleo la unión
europea acabará mirando hacia áfrica
donde además cada vez hay más proyectos
de gas natural licuado y eso puede
beneficiar mucho a países productores de
gas y el petróleo es el por ejemplo en
un futuro cercano a mozambique pero ya
países como angola o nigeria aunque si
sube el precio del transporte esto puede
que no acabe llevando a unas ganancias
reales para la gente provoca
administración y por lo tanto también
protestas
vamos a burkina faso una comisión creada
a principios de febrero por la junta
militar propuso en un informe una
transición de 30 meses antes de volver
al orden constitucional en el informe
fue presentado el miércoles 23 de
febrero al jefe de la junta pero su
contenido no se ha hecho público nuestro
corresponsal en uagadugú nos da los
detalles
dos semanas después de su instalación
los 15 miembros de la comisión técnica a
cargo de adquisición presentaron su
informe al presidente de amiba en una
ceremonia en el palacio con este informe
está compuesto por el proyecto de carta
constitucional para posición la agenda
para posición y una carta de valores
para sustentar la refundación según una
fuente acercan a la presidencia la
duración prevista la disposición es de
30 meses porque según esta misma fuente
el ejército ha expresado su necesidad de
al menos dos años para estabilizar el
país y luego organizar elecciones otras
o command acciones la formación de un
gobierno compuesto de 15 a 20 miembros
como máximo el establecimiento de un
cuerpo legislativo de transición con 51
miembros que uniría a todos los
componentes de la nación es decir la
sociedad civil la política el ejército
sin olvidar los religiosos su mandato no
sería remunerado también se recomendó un
organismo de monitoreo de la transición
que combine civiles y militar para
monitoreo y la validación de la
implementación de la exposición
nuevamente con un mandato no remunerado
hasta aquí las principales
recomendaciones del informe de la
comisión técnica encargada de la
posición próximo paso para el presidente
de amiba la formación de un gobierno de
transición que probablemente debería
ocurrir en los próximos días pasamos
ahora a kenia donde una empresa se
especializó en el reciclaje de sandalias
de plástico para convertirlas en
esculturas y juguetes la creciente
problema de los residuos plásticos está
en el centro de las negociaciones en el
marco de la cumbre de la onu en la
capital de kenia que inició este 28 de
febrero
en redadas en las algas enterradas en la
arena
arrastradas por las rocas las sandalias
de plástico son una plaga en las playas
kenianas este peligro ecológico es
visible por todos lados en la costa de
kenia donde los voluntarios recogen
enormes cantidades de stand alias pero
también botellas de plástico cepillos de
dientes y envolturas de caramelos y
viejos flip flops estas sandalias son el
calzado más común y asequible para mucha
gente ricos pobres todos tienen un par
como son muy baratos cuando se estropean
los tiran y compran unos nuevos así que
terminamos con un montón de sandalias en
nuestras playas
bajo un árbol grandes bolsas llenas de
residuos se clasifican por categorías
los plásticos duros y las botellas de
plástico se venden a recicladores las
sandalias son compradas por ocean soul
la empresa los envía a un taller de la
capital nairobi donde se las limpia para
luego pegarlas para formar placas
multicolores decenas de artesanos las
esculpen después hábilmente para
convertirlas en diversos objetos grandes
y pequeños que encuentran adeptos sobre
todo en el extranjero
voy a retirar las sandalias el océano
salvamos nuestra vida marina amenazada
por la ingestión de estos plásticos
también gracias a las presas de agua a
nuestros ambientes son cada vez más
saludables la mayoría de los artistas
que trabajan aquí proceden de la
industria de la tala de madera así que
también estamos salvando árboles lo cual
es bueno para nuestro medio ambiente
pero la empresa sigue enfrentándose a
una marea de plástico cada año se
acumulan en las aguas del mundo entre 19
y 23 millones de toneladas el 80% del
equipo nacional de ciclismo de ruanda
está conformado por antiguos visita
existas todos los conductores sueñan con
ser profesionales y forman parte del
equipo nacional este fenómeno es aún más
pronunciado en el norte donde se entrena
a la selección nacional mientras toda
ruanda y el mundo del ciclismo estaba
pendiente de las últimas etapas del tour
veamos el siguiente informe de nuestra
corresponsal marian con él
muy sans la capital del ciclismo en
wanda desde hace 4 años cuando un visita
exista a recorrer las calles de esta
ciudad con un sueño y mente convertirse
en ciclista profesional
donde quiere participar un día en el
tour de irlanda pero antes de que ocurra
se contenta con observar a los ciclistas
a la distancia
vamos vamos venga a ver el tour de
ruanda que van a pasar pronto ahora voy
a hacer una pausa en el trabajo los
ciclistas
como recondo muchos visita existe
siempre ha soñado con participar en el
tour de irlanda para algunos de ellos se
ha convertido en una realidad
betclic es un ciclista de 30 años esta
es la décima vez que participa en la
competencia
pero antes de ser profesional fui visita
existe durante casi un año y conocí a
destacados corredores ruandeses y ellos
me ayudaron a entrenar estoy feliz
porque soy profesional he visitado
muchos países del mundo la mañana es san
luis mientras patrick se prepara para
ganar la camiseta amarela del tour de
igualdad jugando acaba de terminar su
jornada de trabajo
esta es mi casa
[Música]
pronto el joven de 20 años quiere
presentarse a las pruebas para entrar en
la selección nacional de juanda pero
para hacerlo debe reunirse los 20
dólares necesarios
aquí es donde guardo el dinero que he
ganado en el trabajo doy una parte para
ayudar a mi familia y la otra al ahorro
para poder participar algún día en las
competencias con el equipo de ruanda
para ganar un juego como de ocasión
concurrido y ocurrido como andy hasta
ahora rukundo ha conseguido ahorrar 6 de
los 20 dólares que necesita para
participar en las competencias del
próximo año su meta es estar en el podio
de los ganadores
hasta aquí en este capítulo de áfrica
siete días recuerde que si quiere
repetir esta u otra misión de nuestro
programa lo puede hacer a través de
nuestra página web www punto frente a 24
punto com
[Música]